foreign
we have a question here from Ben
my name is Ben Yancey I'm from Northern
Kentucky
the thought of everything just kind of
ending really just gives me an empty
feeling in my stomach I was just
wondering you know how do you get past
that everybody dies everybody knows that
the other thing is I'm 42 now but in my
20s not really scared of anything
had a couple kids now like heights
terrify me rainy slippery roads terrify
me is that a symptom of being a parent
and not wanting to leave your children
behind
just wondering about your thoughts
I'm reminded of one of my favorite David
Foster Wallace quotes he said the truth
will set you free
but not until it's had its way with you
and I think one of the things that the
reason we're so reckless as kids and we
do crazy things I used to Donuts on the
highway in my 1981 Buick Regal that's
stupid
right he wants ran to Walmart naked
to Walmart not in Walmart in Walmart and
back yeah yes there's such a big
difference so
we would do these things as kids because
there's this we don't have all the truth
the truth that a lot of things we do are
really dangerous or terrifying
unfortunately the pendulum then swings
the other way and I think it's called
like um what is it called dread stats or
dread data anyway that we now you know
like so for example Ryan you have a
about 1 in 42 million chance of dying
from terrorism oh my goodness and you
even realize that right and we often
treat that the same thing as like that's
more terrifying than dying in a car
crash we have about a one in a hundred
chance of dying in a car crash Josh
and we treat these things as though in
fact the terrorism's far more terrifying
right because we assign some sort of
mental value to it right there's no real
truth I mean the likelihood of anyone in
this room dying from terrorism is so
small that we don't really need to
dedicate a whole lot of mental capacity
toward it and yet the news media and
other sources that bring it to our
doorstep and into our homes they they do
a really good job of terrifying us and I
think that's where Ben is right now is
now everything that wasn't scary at all
to him when he was 20 is so horrifying
that he hasn't found this sort of in
between because it does make sense to be
cautious to look before you leap when
Ryan and I were 15 years old we just
left we didn't look at all right but
where Ben is is in a similar position to
where I am sometimes I'm roughly his age
as well sometimes you just look and then
you refuse to leap at all even though
you've looked and you said oh this is
going to be fine this is going to be
safe but you know what I'm still
terrified yeah so in terms of talking a
bit about emotions fear emotion in
particular like I was sharing earlier
emotions you know are our data they give
information and the biggest piece of
information that fear gives us is
there's a possible threat and to speak
to your point Joshua there's often times
it's it's accurate right looking over
that ledge you know crossing the street
where there's traffic coming it's
appropriate and necessary one might even
say to feel fear in those moments so
that we can register the fear take the
meaning out of it oh okay that my body
is telling that this is possibly unsafe
our body has incredible wisdom for us
now I can make an informed decision
maybe to not cross that street to cross
the street at the light or to do what
have you this is all assuming again that
we are comfortable grounded in our fear
detector if you will is working
accurately and I very interestingly had
almost the opposite experience in
childhood I was riddled with with fear I
did not have that YOLO approach to life
throwing myself I was debilitated by it
and again I understand it very much
through the context of my home living in
a city where there was constant
stressors living in a immediate family
unit where there was a lot of health
related like I was sharing earlier
issues having an emotionally unavailable
mother left me to feel overwhelmed at
all the time so it's understandable then
that laying in bed at night I would race
my mind would race with all of the
things to fear I was quite literally the
little girl afraid of the world and I
would present as much walking around shy
really scared in in outside world and
again when we talk about fear I think to
speak to the first point I made it it
often is appropriate we have to though
understand how equipped we feel to deal
with fear if you're like me and you're
under supported and you're stress
resilience or your ability to tolerate
it what will begin to then do is
misattribute and see things as
threatening that maybe accurately aren't
and or in adulthood maybe we do have the
capacity to deal with so my relationship
with fear really began to shift of
course it was very much a process when I
taught that little girl inside of me
that I I'm not overwhelmed or I don't
have to be overwhelmed I have the
resources to tolerate more and more
stressful scary things in life so that
when I then walk up to the precipice of
something that possibly is threatening I
have a different evaluation system I
have one that more accurately reflects
my adult capacities my adult
relationships and all of the tools that
now my adult body has learned to to
dealt to develop in terms of dealing
with the stress at hand so when we're
exploring our fear we have to understand
that a lot of it is very much accurate
and maybe it is attached to us wanting
to be around for children family loved
ones that we have and we also have to
really explore how competent we feel in
terms of dealing with fear because if we
don't feel like we can tolerate stress
what we'll begin to do is almost
debilitate ourselves not able to leave
the home because everything will feel so
disproportionately threatening and will
feel so under resourced to deal with it
can you talk about some of the tools
that you have in the new a workbook how
to meet Yourself by the way I'll hold it
up if you're watching the video version
can you talk about some of the tools
that will help people deal with fear
specific because you mentioned some of
the tools are there like three that
really just stand out to you 100
actually the whole first section I I
separated the workbook into three major
sections and we begin with the body
developing body Consciousness
reconnecting to our body which is where
our nervous system lives so many Tools
in terms of exercises and caring for our
body including making sure that we're
eating nutrient dense foods making sure
that we're getting the rest we need by
not always being on the go by making
sure that we're sleeping at night on the
same end making sure that we're moving
our body enough paying attention to how
we're breathing we can learn through
consistent lifestyle practices to take
care of our nervous system and we can
also have more directed approaches like
grounding tuning into my physical body
in this moment not lost in my mind maybe
the spiraling thoughts that are causing
anxiety tuning into if for me how does
it feel sitting in this chair with these
lights on me tuning into my breath can I
learn how to intentionally breathe
calmly and deeply from my belly all of
these different in the moment tools we
can use and of course I explore many
more in the first section of the
workbook again intentionally putting it
there because if we don't feel calm and
grounded and safe in our body to proceed
into the next section when we begin to
talk about our mind and our ego and our
shadow and all of the filters that are
coloring how our body is experiencing
the world it's not going to feel like a
safe place to continue that exploration
so there's many daily habits that we can
create and most of them are around
caring for our body because that's where
our nervous system lives to have a
regulated nervous system we have to make
sure we're consistently making sure our
physical needs are met and then again
there's in the moment tools like breath
work like grounding where when we start
to feel scared we can Empower ourselves
to create that safety and to again
relearn that we're not that overwhelmed
child anymore and that we do have have
the resources or the bandwidth or the
stress resilience to create safety even
when it's scary
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free